THOUGHT LAST NIGHT.
WE'LL WAIT FOR THE RACES TO COME
BACK.
I'M PRETTY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THEM
ALL.
HAVE A GREAT SHOW.
>> LAURA: ALL RIGHT, SEAN.
I ENJOYED YOURS.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
THIS IS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
LET'S GETTING RIGHT TO IT.
BIG TAKEAWAYS, THAT'S THE FOCUS
OF TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."  SO, SEAN
ALLUDED TO THIS, THEY'RE
BREATHING A SIGH OF RELIEF AT
THE WHITE HOUSE. EVEN AS
DEMOCRATS ALMOST CERTAINLY WILL
LOSE THE HOUSE.
AND THEY COULD EVEN B LOSE THE
SENATE.
LITTLE ATTENTION IS BEING PAID
TO THE ASTONISHING FACT THAT
DEMOCRATS DO NOT INTEND TO DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY IN THE NEXT
TWO YEARS.
THIS IS WITH 75% FROM FOX NEWS
VOTER ANALYSIS SAYING THEY THINK
THE COUNTRIL RIGHT NOW IS ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
DESPITE THAT, THE WHITE HOUSE
THINKS THEIR POLICIES DON'T NEED
CHANGING.
BECAUSE BIDEN HAS CREATED WHAT
THEY'RE CALLING STABLE,
SUSTAINABLE GROWTH.
>> WHAT DO THE NEXT TWO YEARS DO
YOU INTEND TO DO DIFFERENTLY TO
CHANGE PEOPLE'S OPINION OF THE
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY,
PARTICULARLY AS YOU CONTEMPLATE
A RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2024.
>> NOTHING.
THE MAJOR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WE PASSED -- SOME OF IT
BIPARTISAN, TAKES TIME TO BE
RECOGNIZED.
IT TAKES TIME TO GET IT MOVING.
>> LAURA: THIS IS TYPICAL OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY WIN, THEY THINK THEY WIN.
THEN THEY OVER-READ THEIR
MANDATE.
WELL, YEAH, REPUBLICANS SHOULD
HAVE WON MORE SENATE SEATS.
AND, FLIPPED MORE HOUSE SEATS.
BUT, STILL, THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
WORRYING VOTERS, INCLUDING
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS, IS
INFLATION.
WHICH HE WAS ASKED ABOUT TODAY.
>> THERE WAS A STUDY CONDUCTED
OF BLACK VOTERS WHO SAID
INFLATION WAS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE.
WHAT CAN YOU PROMISE CONCRETELY
IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS, THAT WILL
HELP TURN THE POCKETBOOK FOR THE
BETTER IN THE MIDST OF STAVING
OFF A RECESSION.
>> WHAT I CAN'T DO IS I CAN'T
GUARANTEE THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET RID OF INFLATION.
BUT I DO THINK WE CAN.
WE'VE ALREADY GOT DOWN THE PRICE
OF GASOLINE, ABOUT $1.20 A
GALLON ACROSS THE BOARD.
THE OIL COMPANIES ARE REALLY
DOING THE NATION A REAL
DISSERVICE.
>> LAURA: OH, GOSH, ALL RIGHT.
SO, BIDEN'S REPEATING THAT SAME
LINE.
OH, YOU'RE JUST NOT SEEING THE
GREAT EFFECTS OF MY POLICIES
YET? HE'S SAYING IT TAKES TIME.
BLAMING THE OIL COMPANIES,
REALLY? EVEN CNN WASN'T BUYING.
>> WHEN HE WAS ASKED, WOULD YOU
CHANGE ANYTHING? HE SAID NO.
NOW, YOU HAVE UP 5% OF THE
COUNTRY SAYING THAT WE'RE HEAD
IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
HE SAID HE JUST WOULDN'T DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENT BECAUSE, OF
COURSE, OUR ACHIEVEMENTS TAKE A
LONG TIME TO BE RECOGNIZED.
THAT'S INSULTING PEOPLE.
>> LAURA: THAT IS INSULTING.
AND EVEN DAVID AXELROD SEEMED A
LITTLE LESS THAN ENTHUSED.
>> HE'S PROUD OF WHAT HE DID.
HE WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TELL A
STORY ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
TO BE BIG AND TELL A STORY ABOUT
THE COUNTRY.
IT WAS A MISSED OPPORTUNITY.
>> A FAIR NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T HAVE A FAVORABLE OPINION
OF HIS PERFORMANCE IN OFFICE WHO
VOTED FOR DEMOCRATS BECAUSE IT
WAS ABOUT SOMETHING LARGER.
AND IT WAS ALSO ABOUT THE
ALTERNATIVE.
>> LAURA: BIDEN'S MESSAGE TODAY
FEATURED ALL OF THE USUAL
SLIGHTS OF HAND, JUZ AS IN 2020
WHEN HE CAMPAIGNED THEN ON
UNITING THE COUNTRY, REMEMBER
THAT? ONLY TO GO ON AND BRAND
THE COUNTRY AS SYSTEMICALLY
RACIST AND TRASH TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AS SEMIFASCIST.
TODAY, HE RAISED THE GOAL OF
UNITING AMERICA AGAIN ONLY TO
MAKE FALSE CLAIMS ABOUT
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP AND, OF
COURSE, TO PUSH GUN CONTROL.
>> THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WELL, I SUPPORT THE PROPOSALS
PUT FORWARD BY SENATORS JOHNSON
AND THE SENATOR DOWN IN FLORIDA
TO CUT OR MAKE FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGES IN SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE.
THAT'S NOT ON THE TABLE.
I WILL NOT DO THAT.
I'M GOING TO BAN ASSAULT
WEAPONS.
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY LIKE THE
DEVIL.
>> LAURA: BIDEN'S OBVIOUSLY
LEARNED NOTHING.
AND NOW, "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
PROJECTING THAT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" WILL END UP WITH 50 SEATS
IN THE SENATE AND NARROWLY
CAPTURE THE HOUSE MAJORITY.
SO, THEY'RE TAKING THE HOUSE,
EVEN IF NOT BY THE NUMBERS
OBVIOUSLY THEY HOPED FOR.
THAT WILL DO A LOT TO REIN IN
THE CRAZIEST RADICALISM OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, WE ALL GET
IT, THE GOP IS VERY
DISAPPOINTED.
SO, AN IT THIS POINT, WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT LESSONS WE CAN
TAKE AWAY FROM THE ELECTION.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, THE RED WAVE
DID SWEEP THROUGH FLORIDA AND IT
WAS EVEN MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN
ADVERTISED.
DESANTIS BY 20 POINTS, RUBIO BY
A MASSIVE DOUBLE DIGIT MARGIN,
KNOCKING OFF VAL DEMOCRATINGS
THAT THE DEMOCRATS PEGGED AS A
FUTURE STAR.
>> AFTER FOUR YEARS, THE PEOPLE
HAVE DELIVERED THEIR VERDICT --
FREEDOM IS HERE TO STAY.
I BELIEVE THE SURVIVAL OF THE
AMERICAN EXPERIMENT REQUIRES A
REVIVAL OF TRUE AMERICAN
PRINCIPLES.
FLORIDA HAS PROVED THAT IT CAN
BE TURN.
WE OFFER -- WE OFFER A RAY OF
HOPE THAT BETTER DAYS STILL LIE
AHEAD.
>> LAURA: SO, HE WON MIAMI DADE
AND PALM BEACH COUNTY, WHICH IS
A FEAT FEW THOUGHT WAS POSSIBLE
EVEN A YEAR AGO.
SO, HE, RUBIO, RICK SCOTT, THEY
BUILT A STRONG AND VERY BROAD
GOVERNING COALITION IN FLORIDA,
INCLUDING WITH LATINO VOTERS,
WHO CONTINUE TO MOVE TOWARD THE
GOP THIS CYCLE.
NOW, THIS IS THE FUTURE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SECOND POINT, THE 50-STATE
STRATEGY CONTINUES TO BE THE
BEST HOPE FOR THE GOP GOING
FORWARD.
NOW, WE JUST DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
POWER RIGHT NOW TO STOP THE HARD
LEFT.
AND WE CAN'T GET MORE POWER BY
STAYING HOME AND RUNNING UP BIG
MARGINS IN CLOSE STATES.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
BUT LEE ZELDIN, THINK ABOUT
THIS, GIVEN NO CHANCE FOR MOST
OF THE YEAR, HE CAME WITHIN FIVE
POINTS OF BEATING HOCHUL.
THAT WAS THE BEST SHOWING FOR
ANY NEW YORK REPUBLICAN IN 20
YEARS.
NOW, AS I PREDICTED LAST NIGHT,
THAT PERFORMANCE, FIVE-POINT
MARGIN HELPED REPUBLICANS FLIP
FOUR DEMOCRAT SEATS IN THE
HOUSE.
THIS SENT AOC IN TO APP LEXTY
TODAY.
REAL PROGRESS IN LIBERAL STRONG
HOLDS KEEPS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IN GROWTH MODE.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE.
IN LIBERAL OREGON, CHRISTINE
DRAZEN IS DOWN 3% FROM RADICAL
LEFTIST TINA KOTEK IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE THERE.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE'S MORE WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
BUT FROM OREGON TO NEW YORK AND
OF COURSE IN FLORIDA, WE MADE
BIG PROGRESS.
SINCE WE KNOW DEMOCRAT POLICIES
ARE ONLY GOING TO DRIVE CRIME
AND THE COST OF LIVING HIGHER IN
ALL OF THESE STATES IN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS, REPUBLICAN PROSPECTS
AND RECRUITING SHOULD JUST
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE IN ALL OF
THE STATES.
THIRD, THERE IS NO REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT A MORE
ESTABLISHMENT APPROACH WOULD
HAVE DONE BETTER IN MOST OF THE
SENATE RACES.
NOW, WHILE MANY TRUMP-BACKED
CANDIDATES DID LOSE, McCONNELL'S
FAVORITE CANDIDATE IN COLORADO,
JOE O'DAE GOT ANNIHILATED.
AND THINK ABOUT THIS, MIKE LEE,
HE FOUGHT OFF ROMNEY'S CANDIDATE
IN UTAH, THE TRUMP HATER EDWIN
McMUFFEN.
MURKOWSKI IS BEHIND IN ALASKA
BUT J.D. VANCE WON IN OHIO.
FOURTH, THE RUNOFF IN GEORGIA
COULD WELL DECIDE WHO CONTROLS
THE SENATE AND WHETHER BIDEN
GETS ANOTHER SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE.
SO, ANYONE WHO THINKS OF HIMSELF
OR HERSELF AS A MAJOR PLAYER IN
THE GOP SHOULD BE PLANNING TO GO
DOWN THERE AND WIN THIS
ELECTION.
IT'S FAR MORE IMPORTANT THAN
POINTING FINGERS ABOUT WHO WON
AND WHO LOST LAST NIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS ALIGN ON THIS
TODAY -- THE DEMOCRATS' LINE ON
THIS TODAY IN GEORGIA WAS
PATHETIC.
>> I KEEP LOOKING AT FWA FWA
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S SHOCKING TO ME THAT
HERSCHEL WALKER, WHO CAN BARELY
PUT TWO SENTENCES TOGETHER
SOMETIMES SAYS THINGS THAT DON'T
MAKE SENSE, ASSERTS IT WITH
BRAVADO, TELLS LIES, IS RUDE TO
PEOPLE, IS DOING SO WELL.
>> LAURA: WHOA, SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT HERSCHEL WALKER CAN'T PUT
TWO SENTENCES TOGETHER? THIS IS
THE PARTY OF BIDEN AND NOW JOHN
FETTERMAN.
WE CAN DROP THAT LINE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
WE BLEW GEORGIA, THAT RUNOFF
LAST TIME BY SPLITTING THE PARTY
THERE.
WE CANNOT LET THAT HAPPEN AGAIN.
HERSCHEL WALKER NEEDS TO WIN
THIS.
NOW, WHILE THE LATE BROKE REALLY
APPEARS TO HAVE BROKEN TOWARD
REPUBLICANS, YOU CAN SEE IN THE
EXIT POLLS AND THE VOTE COUNT
FOR ELECTION DAY, THE DEMOCRATS
APPEARED TO HAVE DONE VERY WELL.
AT GETTING A LOT OF VOTES BEFORE
ELECTION DAY.
SO, LOOK, IF EVERYONE HAD VOTED
YESTERDAY, WE MIGHT HAVE SEEN
THE RED WAVE THAT WAS BEING
PICKED UP IN SOME OF THE POLLS.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE ELECTION DAY
ANYMORE.
IT'S MORE LIKE ELECTION MONTH.
AND THAT MEANS THAT GOING
FORWARD, THE GOP CANNOT COUNT
FROM ON THIS COMING FROM BEHIND
STRATEGY IN STATES LIKE NEW YORK
OR VIRGINIA OR MICHIGAN OR EVEN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO BE
READY TO START TURNING OUT THEIR
VOTERS ON THE FIRST DAY OF EARLY
VOTING.
OKAY? AND REPUBLICANS GOING
FORWARD ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
THE SAME.
THEY DID IN THIS IN MIAMI DADE
COUNTY.
THAT WAS FANTASTIC.
WE GOT A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
VOTING EARLY IN MIAMI DAY.
BUT THE OLD TURNOUT MODELS JUST
DON'T WORK ANYMORE, THEY JUST
DON'T.
ALSO, YOU NEED TO BE IN THE
LEAD, FRANKLY, ON LABOR DAY
GOING FORWARD.
THE GOP SHOULD ACT AS IF --
BASICALLY ELECTION DAY COMES
FIVE WEEKS EARLY.
THEY SHOULD JUST PRETEPID B THAT
IT DOES.
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE FIVE POINTS
BEHIND IN LATE SEPTEMBER, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO BANK A
HUGE AMOUNT OF VOTES AGAINST
THEM.
EVEN IF SOME OF THE FOLKS CHANGE
THEIR MIND LATER, IT'S GOING TO
BE TOO LATE.
GOING TO 2024, THE REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO BE LOOKING FOR
CANDIDATES WHO ARE FOCUSED ON
WINNING.
NOT JUST MAKING A POINT OR
SETTLING A SCORE.
SO, TO REALLY CHANGE IT IT,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO WIN AND
WE HAVE TO WIN OVER VOTERS,
OUTSIDE OF OUR TRADITIONAL BASE.
THAT MEANS YOUNG PEOPLE TOO.
THAT'S GOT TO BE THE GOAL FOR
THE NEXT PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE POPULOUS MOVEMENT IS ABOUT
IDEAS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ANY ONE PERSON
IF THE VOTERS CONCLUDE THAT
YOU'RE PUTTING YOUR OWN EGO OR
YOUR OWN GRUDGES AHEAD OF WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY, THEY'RE
GOING TO LOOK ELSEWHERE, PERIOD.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE NEXT
TAKEAWAY.
>> ONE MORE THING, WE'RE GONE
AND NO LONGER DISCUSSING A
PRIMARY FOR JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING.
HE IS ABSOLUTELY GOING TO BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR PRESIDENT
AND EVERYONE IS JUST DONE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> LAURA: WELL, YESTERDAY'S
RESULTS WILL LIKELY SILENCE TALK
OF REPLACING BIDEN ON THE
TICKET.
>> I HOPE JILL AND I GET A
LITTLE TIME TO ACTUALLY SNEAK
AWAY FOR A WEEK AROUND --
BETWEEN CHRISTMAS AND
THANKSGIVING.
MY GUESS WILL BE EARLY NEXT YEAR
WE MAKE THAT JUDGMENT.
BUT, MY PLAN TO DO IT NOW.
>> TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS IN
EXIT POLLS SAY THEY DON'T THINK
YOU SHOULD RUN FOR RE-ELECTION.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM?
HOW DOES THAT FACTOR TO YOUR
FINAL DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT TO RUN FOR RE-ELECTION.
>> IT DOESN'T.
>> WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO THEM?
TO THE TWO-THIRDS --
>> WATCH ME.
>> LAURA: NOW, ANOTHER DEMOCRATS
ARE FEELING GUOED, BUT THIS MAN
IS STILL UNPOPULAR.
AND HE'S ALSO CLUELESS -- SO
CLUELESS, HE THINKS HE HAS A
MANDATE FROM LAST NIGHT FOR
BOONE DOGS.
>> SOMEONE IN -- UP IN SCRANTON,
PENNSYLVANIA, THE CONGRESSMAN
GOT ELECTED. HE SAID, CAN YOU
HELL US MAKE SURE WE'RE ABLE TO
HAVE HIGH-SPEED RAIL SERVICE
FROM SCRANTON TO NEW YORK.
NEW YORK CITY? I SAID, YEAH, WE
CAN.
WE CAN.
FIRST OF ALL, IT WILL MAKE IT A
LOT EASIER TAKE A LOT OF
VEHICLES OFF OF THE ROAD.
WE HAVE MORE MONEY IN THE POT
NOW.
>> LAURA: I HEARD THAT AND
ALMOST FELL OFF OF THE CHAIR.
BIDEN ADMITTED IN THIS SPEECH
THAT HE CAN'T GUARANTEE THAT HE
CAN SOLVE INFLATION -- THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR VOTERS.
BUT BECAUSE SOME NEW CONGRESSMAN
CALLS HIM ABOUT A HIGH-SPEED
RAIL IN SCRANTON, HE'S LIKE, NO
PROBLEM, WE'LL GET THAT DONE.
I MEAN, COME ON.
NOW, LAST NIGHT'S RESULTS
NOTWITHSTANDING, VOTERS REPORTED
THEY STILL DO TRUST REPUBLICANS
MORE ON THE ISSUES THEY CARE
ABOUT THE MOST.
AND IF THE DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO
PRESIDE OVER THE TYPE OF
ECONOMIC AND CRIME PROBLEMS THAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST YEAR,
EVEN EARLY VOTING WILL NOT BE